well this sucks oh right how long are we
supposed to be here
Isaac Samus found an amazing sniper's
nest right above you hey do you ever
notice the bad video quality on these
hologram screams I know it's so crappy
sometimes it doesn't even play in color
and when it does it's just blue you
switched the holo screens from 2108 and
after 400 years we still haven't even
improved on it it's even more
disappointing than my iPhone you still
got it throw that away
nope but remember the original TVs they
were updated like every three years HD
plasma even that crazy thing to shot
lasers into your brain we should that it
sounds awesome it was but if you use it
too much you get that one brain disease
which one you know the one where your
head liquefies oh yeah I actually use
one of those laser thing was really yeah
I was at an antique shop looking for a
porcelain unicorn and I saw it just
sitting there in the corner
I was watching reruns of house well
that's cool but I why were you shopping
for a porcelain unicorn statue I don't
know you well enough to answer that
question what the chief knows why are
you why can't I know coz rest too many
questions now guys about that turret
I'll take care of it
hey I think they stopped we shouldn't
trust it they're just trying to trick us
only one way to find out are you done
being I'm sorry you guys just run out of
ammo
darn it stop shooting why would we do
that you would do it out of the kindness
of your own heart and compassion for
your fellow man no that's stupid okay
that's it thank you no thank you
wait the signals breaking up again teeth
I can't hear you
good job Master Chief you're the
greatest sniper in the universe your
skills are unmatched by any assassin why
thank you mr. president of Earth every
movement in the universe loves you
because they do mr. president we need
you to assassinate this guy who is a big
stupid jerk I have a visual on him hey
wait why were we here in the first place
we were bored and chief burned all of
our DVDs after he spilled and even that
one Bruce Willis movie blind date no the
one with the ghost oh yeah yeah so you
suggested that we stop the largest
terrorist organization in history on an
uncharted planet - oh yeah it's not my
fault you're an arsonist
remember that bomb store or that gas
station or the lighter fluid factory
that last one was my favorite
ha eat karma yeah firestarter are you
okay I think so is that all of it
wait hold on got to take care of
something revenge yeah
get down your quick oh good you're here
hey chief you said you were looking for
something a few minutes ago what's in it
a detonator some guns a popsicle and a
syringe with some Thai yellow glue guys
we got one extra yes take it out I don't
know I don't want to touch it
it's here let me fix it
ah you injected me yep I think we should
leave now
are we there yet no are we there yet no
no we're 50,000 light years away from
home we're not gonna get there in ten
minutes
oh oh hey knock it off you two don't
make me come back there so help me I
will turn this spaceship around improve
it Donald's we're in space how would we
do that mom she'd let me go to
McDonald's what are we there yet either
one of you guys says are we there yet
one more time I'm gonna shoot myself in
the face and you guys can fly yourselves
home yet
you guys suck
you